persone allora oggi sono in tema perché
uno con fran domestica quindi mi sono un
po p2
perché oggi faremo una puntata di
unboxing un pochettino più soft e
siccome non mi intendo io di cose
caricari nei soft ho deciso di prendere
una persona e di invitarla qua per
questo episodio unboxing che sicuramente
sa come facciamo entrare la special
guest in questo momento dentro il mio
umile divano per prato umile di mano
contro il di cancro il divano mai e
mettono in scia fonici questo dimostri
di dentro divano grazie aver riportato
la scatola non aprirla ma a me sembra
solo questa soap riuscire grazie ragazzi
allora oggi faremo ma devi uscire il
servizio corriere oggi faremo un ambo
xing sto scherzando vini quali si dove
hai preso questa scatola nera portato ma
guarda quanto inventati piacerà
tantissimo contenuto sento centro fumo
della scarsa ci sono nè rose custodie
meno questo sarà meglio amelio mi meglio
con un vero cannes
io non so cosa ci sarà all'interno
marino piace direi che possiamo
appoggiarlo sul tavolino e dall'inizio
all'unboxing vuoi essere tu come vai tu
l'onore di aprirla bray fanno piano
perché c'è un effetto sonoro nibali
riuscito a metter l'effetto sonoro così
perché contro il cielo fatto perfetto
non mi sa che hai sbagliato non ho
sbagliato 96 sasha no no non può non
guarda che faccio altri video facciamo
iniziare alle cose piccole di video da
di essere un po ma no vabbè magari o
degli appuntamenti o a tutto per quello
di sai che superano bene però devi farmi
non platinette di banana oltre quella
possiamo partire unbox andò la prima
cosa che vedo che devo solo capire che
cos'è
non me ne andrò in capirlo anch'io
flowers face al roller e c'è una figura
di un'attiva che fattosi prego scarpa lo
è usiamolo subito ma che non penso sia
un trucco
quest'ultima stagione era fermo sia
scritto di fare così come mi sento più
intelligenti di prima stiamo vedendo un
parere non stai facendo male
sabrina va bene così adesso iniziale
dovrebbe via certi però non mi piace mi
fa abbastanza
vuoi provare ma è una tortura cinese sta
roba
invece bevanda che non lo sai pari dove
centro della bellissima anche l'altra
faccia dolce mi piace è una cosa
fondatore di squadra sono aperte di
recente lasciamola ai sa bene clio
scrivici un commento cosa serve la roba
lì tranquillo passa pure allora miss di
tutti credo si riferisca sicuro non a me
miss beauty parliamo di questo è il coso
per prendere le farfalle un anno ho
capito quando sei stanco tanto io tra
sembrava addormentarti con siena ma cosa
sul serio allora non dimenticarti di
pulirlo si va vengono nello sport forse
per bocchetti le labbra guarda
laura fa ne abbia trovato e cosa no no
no no no un quasi stellari ho una
dignità
la prima a sabrina sabrina
allora è veramente così ve lo spiego
praticamente mente quando venite
pennarelli e all'orizzonte è quello mai
parma senza accesso è per gonfiare le
labbra next sul prossimo e piccolo
quindi danno non lo può fare silver ed è
un pò tutti giapponese sempre in alto
realtà trovavi me allora questo 4 infili
nel naso ha già pagato per la piscina
non certo pato disposero perché alien
trovata perché allora ecco per cantare
ramazzotti il domani qualcosa sarà è
perfetto per chi male il problema marito
non sapremo mai google è perché ha
scritto veramente sotto di giappone è
sempre un tappo a naso giappone va bene
ma c'è anche destra sinistra cioè
sofisticato denti next tridenti grossi
ma e non abbiamo bisogno abbiamo già
subito ragione però guardiamo almeno
come kit ci sono denti in scatola
bellissimo ci sono delle siringhe grande
ma no ma io so che cos'è guarda lory è
una cinesata che non funziona si dimette
leggere studenti poi accendi questo
nuovo diventato blu degli altri studenti
vedi allora generale su tutte anche blu
ma i casi e ora devi stare così per 10
minuti
pianti il prossimo roso però non so
neanche come di scriverli stick beauty
in strumento significa strumento di
bellezza ma anche se è già bellissimo
però cosa riusciamo a fare un unboxing
della boxing fatto che la scatola
promette bene a 6
wow urne sembra un tele prova a
rispondere al telefono sia a me sembra
molto un telefono mi senti si mandano a
riguardo perché i tasti non mi piace non
lo fare bene non lo faranno fare non
affidati al loro dolore guardaroba ma
vuoi mettere i vari ma cosa serve
angeles ma prego dimmi che quello con il
percorso e button a melito al the bottom
d'amico allora questa fare una maschera
ghost ce ne sono due perché è una oggi
una domani ai presenti che quando l'età
avanzati si scollano un pezzo di faccia
questo è per tenerti la faccia bella
tonica quindi gara si apre così ok ti
apro l'occhio devi tenerlo a 5 minuti e
poi avrai una pelle che qualsiasi donna
ti invidia c'è ragazze sembra un fort
cosa di qualche videogioco 26 vigore
moon e de maio bravissimo e vogliamo
vedere come votato faccia se è pronta
muoviti un po parla se ti senti diverso
voglio morire tra lory non devi darti la
faccia valeria tra i vari
[Musica]
dai su mercato a finire questo video per
l'inter ma qui non voglio diventarlo
prima a premere che è stato nei sogni
allora vedi più essa o anna una domanda
essa o anna quando mi piace di più o
meno di un po casa grazie ad eventi tra
gli occhi come farebbe una vera
principessa
oh mio dio 6 capelli stai facendo come
anna che tu mi hai chiesto anna manna di
frozen certo non è detto subito se già
sveglio pure dormi giochiamo insieme da
i quad ami bello abbinamento col
cappellino fai una figura con le parole
liner senti possiamo finire questo senso
e supplizio poi la marina posso portare
la casa di sarah senti fai quello che
vuoi basta che la cina ti prego era
presa più brutta che abbiamo infatti in
un video non sono mai stato truccato in
un video e non penso che debba essere la
prima volta la prima volta allora se
devi sorridere fa tipo così perché devo
metterti il blush
[Musica]
da provare il pesce tifosi un po di più
perché devo vedere la cassetta di ronta
le segnano fare pesce anche poi a te
piace labbro più carnoso me piace la
labbra più carnose questo quali più
grosso in teoria però sotto andrebbe
faccio una base di rossettini a 3 no io
penso che tua mamma rimarrebbe incantata
da questo trucco questa giornata
ok ora di fare però semenya nominati
sembro jeffrey non sei di altri stare
aspetta c'è anche nei denti toglierlo
dai gay da me lo sbiancamento 6 conto
no è una cosa che mai qualcosa nella
vita sono bellissimo come parli si
voglia dire neanche lo stesso scrive
bene andiamo via da questo posto
immediatamente che non ti sei divertito
molto e non esci così di casa oggi è
anche se qualcuno vede solo questo frame
di un video potrebbe farci miglia di me
completamente sbagliata quindi un po
meritori di stage la ricky è un balsamo
chi era per farlo scorso del mcdonald's
governando in italia non fa niente è
stato ss burger king e vabbè vabbè basta
chiudiamo è stato rivelato ragazzi spero
che questo video vi sia piaciuto questo
era l'unboxing con sabrina e stato un
momento particolarmente felice non ti
azzardare ti ammazzo quindi ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto
ringrazio sabrina per questo è questa
esperienza magica unica magica credibile
e noi ci vediamo al solito ad un
prossimo vino belle ragazze
[Musica]